[Music]
all right
let's do this um
welcome everyone my name is
jared williams i'm the co-founder and
current director of
mindstraw festival um lion's jaw
is an annual experimental performance
and dance festival um
[Music]
it's located in boston massachusetts and
cambridge massachusetts
this is unseated nitmock
massachusetts and wampanoag territories
and that acknowledgement is so important
and covers both where i'm standing now
but also
the location of mit
um which is our co-producer
of this year um
many of you we experienced great loss
with the sort of um
pandemic and we were really looking
forward to our first time
working with mit and being able to be in
this beautiful space
but they have been incredibly supportive
through this process
and have helped make this talk possible
and yeah so i just wanted to thank them
and
um susan wilson will will step on in a
second and
say a few words um i also want to thank
our panel we had an amazing
time last night um with erica nichols
and jess pretty
and thomas de france um
joins us again with save martha harjono
and
joseph pierce today i'm super excited
um so yeah i think that's it
we're gonna have a little q a at the end
if there's time so feel free to put in
any questions you have in the chat
i'll try to collect them um
and again i'll be posting things
intermittently in the chat
regarding the asl and payment and things
like that
so susan do you want to say a few things
sure mostly just um a thank you to all
of you and all of these wonderful
panelists and artists that jared and
tommy have put together
it's really a fantastic lineup and we
could not be more proud and honored to
um
be a part of making it happen um so just
keeping that as short as possible so we
can maximize the time we have with
everybody here
i'll pass it right around to the
incomparable tommy de france
thank you so much susan and we thank our
friends at mit
um which is a pretty amazing place as
i'm sure we all have
opinions or thoughts about it and susan
and jay scheib are
doing important work for us to imagine
spaces where
queer futures can be materialized
i broadcast from durham north carolina
in a space on the campus of duke
university
which is on the ancestral lands of the
chicory the ino
and the catawba people
i want to start with a gesture to ground
the us of me and all the ghosts who are
here and their many
and ancestors as well so i'll
light a candle
and i will bring queer kindred
into the space with me and especially
those queers who found their way to
resistance
as a strategy of survival
started easy with this acknowledgement
and want to offer this out to
the panelists who are with us tonight
and i ask you to
i don't know share your acknowledgement
or welcome yourself for
you know be with us now as you will let
us know what you're thinking in terms of
how shall you prefer to be addressed by
others
this evening and thank you
hi um i'm joseph pierce
i am a citizen of cherokee nation
um so
i'm glad to be connected to tommy
who is on lands that are not too far
from
my people's ancestral homeland um
i'm calling or i'm zooming in now from
brooklyn um which is
the ancestral homeland of the lenape and
canarsie peoples
um and i'm really glad
to participate um with everyone
um and i'm glad to call in the ancestors
to be with us today um i'm glad to be
accompanied by them
um and all of you um i'm
a professor at stony brook university
which is on long island
where i teach about
latin american literary and cultural
production queer
theory and native american and
indigenous studies
um i
also am a co-curator
with sj norman of a performance series
called knowledge of wounds
which centers
indigenous and queer indigenous bodies
in relation
which had its first iteration um
this past january at performance space
new york
um so i'd also like to to bring in some
of that
um that labor that work and that energy
to this space
as well um and and sj from
from australia so that's all thanks
good evening everyone my name is zave
marta hargiono
i'm zooming from my living room
uh which is in my home of 14 years
which is in the neighborhood of bed stuy
one of the most incredible uh
stakes in black history in this country
and is also
on unseated lenape ho king
i grew up in queens
and i'm bringing
in today certainly for this conversation
and just
generally right now i'm bringing in uh
caretakers all my caretakers
be them my ancestors and
my present caretakers my my queer
my queer kin family and
my future caretakers and
i bring in also my identity as as a
caretaker
[Music]
and i think that in the yeah i think
it's i'm trying to figure out how to
identify with
my artwork as a as a dance maker
as a performance artist um
and maybe right now all of the labor is
caretaking
so even in
in in making art over the past few years
it has been so much about
care um exchanges of care so that we can
labor together and work together and
take care of ourselves
to stay sustained into into long
long features of art making and shift
all of that as
as is needed
thank you for that and yeah i wonder we
i think we should just start
there because that's where we are this
is our
our presenting for now is this this idea
of care
and care taking i'm thinking of how um
christina sharp you know in her um in
the wake
uh offers up this introduction where she
has this sort of repeated um
statement that thinking requires care
and it's so obvious and it's something
that you know so many
artists or experimental makers would
would maybe know but not necessarily
enact in relationship to other people
and that's always been a little bit of a
struggle
for makers i think in a way and we've
seen all kinds of
uncaring sort of structures of company
but
as we imagine queer caring and thinking
and thinking requiring care
does that resonate in the a real nowness
of now
in terms of rona and and separations
and you know disembodied relationships
now how is how is care
showing up now as a thinking practice
and a making practice
for you
all right you should go you should go
okay
i have two simultaneous thoughts right
one is if we took care to think which
also meant being more critical i think
of
our own thought patterns
we could collectively change the way
that we think and think more together
and that is like
for me a kind of
aspirational political act is to take
more care in our thinking in our speech
and
and everything that tumbles from that
and i'm
always hesitant to focus so much on
thought
and intellect just because so much of
our wisdom
comes from our body and that wisdom is
historically
erased for folks of color you know
um gut thinking gut knowledge
gut wisdom is in the colonial paradigm
below the head and so there's this
conditioning that especially assimilated
folks like myself
have gone through so it's like yes and
yeah and that that makes me think
of i mean we could go we could go
through the whole history of like the
humors versus the rational self
versus you know you know we could we
could go through all of that but
i think in this moment um we're seeing
how um care
and embodiment is becoming so much more
central to the way
um that people are thinking and enacting
precisely because
it is so limited in this moment
and and so um the
the question of touch and of
proximity that was described in the
panel
yesterday um i think also relates
to care in this in the sense that
when we care for
we are always in relation to and with
and because of that we are
necessarily reaching out and gesturing
towards a type of relationality that is
inherently decolonial
and and because we are not singular
beings and and simply by
acknowledging that we are already
positioning ourselves
orienting ourselves in a way that allows
for um greater resilience and
survivance and and caretaking
and i think that that i mean it can be
really simple um
but but it's also hard to to enact um
because of the structural and historical
limitations that have
that have been constructed around our
our bodies and our in our communities
there's something about bodies and time
i'm thinking
so i know that when um christina sharp
writes that
uh as i try to work through that in my
own like
in studio practice or being alongside
others
this kind of care
becomes manifest in some ways through
expressions of time
like not just rushing in and thinking i
got it or
i can help you get it now like you'll
just get it because i want you to get it
whatever the it is that needs to be
gotten
but something about time that seems also
in this formation that maybe we could
sort of think through together a little
bit um
caregiving bodies and then time because
you know time
has an influence also on how we
experience
uh the possibilities of body and and
where they can move
and how they move and where they want to
go next if you will
what about that time in terms of care
yeah my my mind was going there actually
that just
thinking about what care and
relationship
actually require is time and i think so
much about
slowing down just slowing down not only
the way we make together the amount of
hours we spend together slowing down the
process
of even identifying okay here i am
here i am with another person for
example or here i am with a set of folks
and we're trying to make something
together um
slowing down all of the assumptions
slowing down the the
that rapid fire what are we here for
what do we need to do how much time do
we have all of that
and i've been thinking also about labor
the care
labor and and i think queer
caretaking also is this sort of
necessarily a community experience i
mean
i think i learned
big forms of caretaking
in queer community as a young person
because so many folks
in queer community we have we have one
another and and that's what we've got
um and
and the labor of caretaking for
ourselves
in inside of caretaking for others it's
it's a lot of it's a lot of work
actually and this moment of political
collapse and um
you know genocide and violence all kind
of
you know climate injustice all kind of
swirling together
i think is really for me
pulling back any whatever sheer
veil there was that you know i was under
no impression that we had a system of
care
um you know for us publicly but
kind of really like just knocking the
last legs down
on the concept that there is um
there are structures of care that look
after society and look after communities
so these care structures that are just
already there
that are now getting to
see this shine and this light put around
them
like oh yeah mutual aid networks or
community
um efforts like these are things that
have always been there and have
been always keeping so many of us
thriving and surviving
um and now there's kind of an actual
maybe a mainstream attention to
these cultures of care um
i i wonder if that's what's
i happening i think um
that in a way
so time is something that i could talk
about forever
nice well done i love to talk about
um no
um a phrase i learned i mean every sort
of
like racialized group has their own
time um and
and with um with sj norman we
will talk about being on black fella
time which is
like how they describe it in australia
among aboriginal communities
indigenous communities and you know to
be an indian time
but i think that there's there's a way
that it's not just being 15 minutes late
for everything
but but enacting a type of
um uh
ancestral relation that
is um
that that places us in
in a longer tradition and history
and so we who have been here for 30 000
years
know about time
and we know how to situate ourselves
within the long durati of historical
moments
this is why care for me in this moment
actually um depends very heavily
on that long memory
because because when i hear people talk
about
the apocalypse or
the breakdown of the political system i
think
i think to what my ancestors must have
thought
i think about what they
survived i i think about the fact
that when
cherokee people were forced
to leave our traditional homelands we
brought with us
the sacred fire that burned at the
center of every
village every town and so the fire was
brought
the coals were brought in
little moss baskets
and those are the same coals that were
used to start
the fire again after the trail of tears
and that is care that
is a form of long historical care
and remembering that is so important
for our communities and and so i think
for me
it's it's like situating myself in that
longer history
is also a form of care because it is
ancestral care
so i mean i think that's also savvy
that's kind of what you were talking
about with like body memory
you know um we we have
these these memories embedded within our
sinews and it's it's in
recognizing and and feeding those
memories
that we are able to um
or that i am at least am able to
um to not imagine that this is the first
apocalypse that we have seen
you who have survived no this is not
new this is structural this has been
here for a long time this is the way
white people want it to be
so like i'm not i'm not dismissing
the current moment but i do that we have
the ability
to see our survival as having emerged
through a much longer history of um
of futurity which which in some cases
um like is an ancestral futurity
is that is the type of relationship that
i'm interested in cultivating
um in spiritual practice and in arts
practice
and in in you know the stuff that i'm
writing um and this is something that's
developed
you know through um talking with other
native folks with talking with sj norman
i was talking with
um dev and emery uh talking with people
who have this practice of care
but it's it's an it's an ancestrality
that is
emergent towards the future
yeah i hear that
yeah i i think i'm also something that's
swirling in my mind is
that that body memory which is both
a place to lean on or a place to pull
from or a place to be in
and also the the ways in which
i think trauma and stress
is also is also part of our body
memory um and i think
i definitely something i'm just feeling
you know over the past seven months is
this experience
of encountering my own
um you know
physicalized stress mental stress and
all these things
decision fatigue and so on and so forth
and
encountering that um so much trauma and
anxiety in
in so many of the people who are
caretaking for me and and we're really
like caring for
each other and ourselves um under a kind
of
heightened in a heightened physical
place and so i've been thinking i've
been kind it's kind of been dawning on
me actually this week
that i'm like oh you know what we're
we're kind of doing this
this you know everyday life kind of
shift
we're doing it right now this is sort of
our seventh or eighth month
of this particular kind of
way of being with each other and and
this
practice of of um understanding
uncertainty on a really
daily level and making a lot of
decisions constantly
around health and care and basic
um needs and so
yeah i i i would i would love to
kind of touch in more you know with
with other folks on a constant or
consistent basis
kind of to remember that the rattling is
also
[Music]
a flushing back of of memory
um from from times that our ancestors
have survived
i was thinking a bit about um
how we talk about trauma and
and sort of expression the expression of
trauma that
you know comes through uh experience but
also through memory and
then sometimes it's it's experienced and
expressed through
a kind of um physicality that might not
be
in the front of a consciousness and
there's this
you know more recent work in epigenetics
that's trying to help us understand
especially for
people of color living under white
supremacy which would be everyone on
planet
um is living under white supremacy and
then how epigenetics
are trying to narrate or help us
understand
tendency and again orientation
through genetic expression
is in some ways kind of related to you
know viral
transmissions and so we're kind of in
the i'm just
i'm affirming what i heard you both say
that we're in this
and we've been in this before we were in
it with hiv
when we were trying to figure out new
caretaking strategies
across queer communities or if they were
the same gender 11 communities then or
still are however they were um naming
themselves in each other and yeah this
this sort of
concern with illness and non-normativity
um
maybe we could turn towards as we're
thinking of ancestors then
are we thinking of kin and what is
kinship
in this construction of a kind of um
ancestral possibility
and especially in terms of our queer kin
kindred or queer
queer ancestors how do we find them how
are they
helping us make or survive or strategize
or
caretake
kinship is also something that i love to
talk about
i would i would um
i think that um
some of my thoughts about this
one one thing that i that i would like
to say about kinship is that
it is not as normative
as people
often think it is and i don't think that
we need to let
normative capture
kinship as often as we do
um in some of my earlier
academic work um one of the things that
i tried to
um show is how
um
the normative family model is
is constantly breaking fracturing
from within and this is why it has to be
so closely guarded
in modernity this is why white supremacy
and normative kinship
go hand in hand with capitalist
accumulation
because it is only in maintaining those
structures
that those systems are able to
grow and expand and metastasize
um to use and to use a
a metaphor um
but i think
too that
kinship is also
a
a type of ethical relationship that we
have
with other beings that is not limited to
the human
and this is something that native
communities
have always known um and this is
something that
um that i've been thinking about more
recently
um drawing on
um work by karen recollett
in toronto and emily johnson
here in new york to describe
constellations and conciliatory
practices which are grounded in
indigenous epistemologies of
relation and care so
um for example
yeah if i can just tell a tiny story
um so there's a story in the cherokee
tradition
of the um
the pine tree and the pine tree
and the stars so there were a group of
boys and all that the boys wanted to do
was dance
they just love to dance and
one of the boys um always would get the
others to dance and they would dance
around and around and around and the
mother
thought that this wasn't exactly right
because they were not doing their chores
um they were dancing instead and so one
day
um the boys um
sat down to dinner and the mother wanted
to punish them and she gave them
rocks in their in their dinner
in their porridge and they ate this and
they got really mad
and they went outside to just dance so
they go outside and they dance
and they're dancing and dancing and
dancing and they start to
rise to levitate and
up towards the sky and the mother comes
out and is very afraid
and she grabs one of them um and
not wanting to but she pulls him down to
the ground
and he hits the ground with so much
force
that the ground swallows him up and the
other boys
kept on circling and rising and they
become
the constellation that we know as the
pleiades
and the the boy who fell to the ground
became
the pine tree and so the pine tree
grows up to reconnect
with his brothers the stars and
in a way this is the type of
relationship
that i think we're talking about
when we say kinship when we say
constellation
in which it is a
a yearning towards a seeking to be with
that is not necessarily um
limited to the human form but in this
case in the case of the story
it is human and tree and star
and there are other stories that we have
and that other communities have
that that demonstrate this type of
relationality
but these are the types of things that
i think we need to be
grounding ourselves in and i use that
word very advisedly
um grounding ourselves in those stories
that teach us
how to reach across the breach between
human and other than human or between
the material and the spiritual or
between
land and sky um
so that's what that's a story that i
keep on trying to
to to think about and to keep with me
that is a story about care and about
relationship
building
we're i think we're in the story still
and imagining it and you know it's the
the the time it takes to register
and and and process and consider and
and respond really you know we need our
new colored people time and zoom
which is okay it's okay
and our queer time savvy did you want to
come in
yeah i'm just as you told that story i
just
i saw the whole thing i saw every image
um it yeah i wasn't watching i
i felt that i was in a forest
seeing seeing it all and
yeah maybe circling a little back to
this idea of the time that it takes to
think
with consideration to act with
consideration to
um
[Music]
to be in relationship with consideration
and then also i think that
you know i i i can be sometimes a very
action oriented person so
i like the idea of mobilizing community
in consideration um
yeah it's bringing me back to this this
idea of what is the
when we are when we are connected across
right across species
with our with our with our environment
with
our climate with each other across those
breaches that
that you just named um
the process looks really different to
develop
relationship the process looks really
different to
um being conversation and caretake and
i've been thinking so much about that
culture
actually right so so stepping away from
the understanding of the word culture as
specific to ethnicity or geography
really cultures
of of relationship and
i think about it in terms of what kind
of
homes communities environments get to
happen
when we culture shift you know towards
care and and centering collectivity
and then also what does our art making
and our creative practice
look like when that when cult that same
culture shift happens
what does our community organizing look
like when that culture shift happens and
i think it's all there i think it's
actually
all there um
and it's it and it's also i've been
wondering if
if this is about making cultural
agreements
together in collective
that we have to
we have to unwind collectively the ways
that we're conditioned to be in
relationship
and it's actually really urgent right
now
it's always been urgent but it's really
urgent because i'm
seeing the bifurcation especially of of
sort of
um political culture in
north america and then in other global
in other nations and other parts of the
world that are experiencing fascism on
this particularly acute level
there are kinds of these multiple
cultures that are very much in
antagonist relationship
and um so it's these belief systems
um and value systems and culture systems
and
obviously that's zooming out a little
bit too
wide for any kind of um
you know comfortable level but i think
i i then when i think really
expansively about that this global
climate of fascism that we are in
together globally with so many
communities around the world
then i kind of i'm like okay that's
that's that's
time and then me my life
my kin my family my
communities people that i don't know
that i care deeply for and then
try to support in any way that i can um
so it's like macro and micro at the same
at the same time
and that kind of connection i think is
really meaningful too
um not just thinking about my little
world but understanding that inherent
connection to these
global experiences that people i will
never meet
are also suffering and surviving as we
are
in in my little corner in brooklyn
i think it's a super important point
around
the materialization of black as
an outcome of chattel slave trade
you know produces the idea of black
not a black person but a black as a
black
a plastic zucchia jackson calls it a
plasticity
that's not human and not human
simultaneously
you know here not here
but then as sort of a global possibility
of black people
responding to blm along with you know
many other people who responded to what
was happening in north america in terms
of the very particular fascism
and at the same time the particular
experiences in different parts of the
planet are quite different
so there are people you know trying to
get into the system as makers if you
will
um you know algerians living in the
south of france who are trying to get
into a choreographic center
having really different sort of concerns
around what they imagine as a next thing
to be
or do from the kind of conversation we
might have here
um you know through lion's jaw and our
assembly
what do we make of that it's really i'm
trying to pose it as a question of
orientation
and to face towards each other means
we're
in some ways maybe turning away from
those other structures that were never
made for us or serving
us what about that so maybe you can
start there if you like but
what are we turning from and how do we
connect to people who are
turning towards those systems that some
of us
are thinking are already bankrupt
yeah i yes turning
away from and then i'm also
thinking opening up towards letting in
and the word remembering joseph you know
reinviting
or allowing you know all of these all of
these action verbs
um i think this is a wonderful question
for this moment of
you know so people so many people around
me are qualifying this moment
um 2020 in north america as
uncertain a time of uncertainty and
from my meditation practice it's like no
i
there's no time that's certain no such
thing as certainty
to begin with so practicing uncertainty
is actually a really
important spiritual practice and it's
really really really like
advanced you know when you get into get
into those kinds of like teachings
um i think
i think the uncertainty is the part that
maybe holds
some of us back i mean the my
collaborators
uh rahab nam and ube halaya and i were
um on the video the other day in our
rehearsal and
we had a moment of really
just taking some breaths and talking
about how we're grieving the american
dream
that our immigrant ancestors
really really that
had to suffer so much to to for us to
now all be you know in canada and in the
us
um when we're all from um southeast asia
or
iran that's where we are from
um and grieving that the american dream
not believing in any sense right but
grieving
the the grief of our
our parents our our grandparents who had
to
uh you know put so much effort and labor
into believing in something that just
ultimately ends up giving them nothing
and us nothing and
here we are oddly in the same place
grappling with these questions about
the void of disconnection from our own
communities on some transnational level
and then
how do we take care of our families and
ourselves when
really there's nothing you know there's
not really a social system here for
for immigrant folks for so many folks um
[Music]
and it was like it was this really deep
emotional moment that just kind of
happened
unexpectedly and so that's what's coming
to mind right now is
this uncertainty right like what we may
believe
will get us something clout um
[Music]
the spotlight uh a means of survival
income
[Music]
recognition yeah i don't know i mean
not sure and certainly definitely not
less sure now
this reminds me a little bit of um
the artist demian dene yaze
who's danae and some of their
graphic um art and some of their poetry
that um talks about
um the american dream
and they have a um a performance called
shatter um that that they
um have performed recently along with
uh kevin holden um as part of
um tba festival that's that's run out of
pica
in portland and um
they they take um
caricatures of indigenous
faces bodies you know pocahontas
those things and um
at the end of a very arduous performance
they
they um shatter these images
and i think that's kind of what's
happening you're actually talking about
there too is the shattering of that
image of the american dream which which
is
um which was always constructed
as a caricature um
and so we get to this idea of
what is um the face
and what is the caricature or what is
the mask and
um i think that the
the realities of
capitalist extraction are
being laid bare in a more
visible and visceral way than than
we have seen and that
in conjunction with the broad
swell of black lives matter
um both in the us and globally
i think also to brazil i think to
france where black bodies
are resisting the
colonial interpolation um
that franz fanon describes um
and then i also um i think that
there's a there's a way that all of this
defies description
um without the use of
nouns that are also verbs so we were
talking about
the doing right and and um
this is why i really
um i think it's important for us to
[Music]
to be theorizing and pushing language
and pushing conceptually um which may
not necessarily mean only being
future or or forward
oriented but also um can
bring in concepts and ideas and and
forms from the past
such as like um cherokee language
like many indigenous languages are so
verb centric or so action-centric
um there are like
it's like 80 percent nouns and
and you know 20 um sorry 80
verbs and like percent nouns sorry
though the way around
such that that any
um any
action is always in relation to other
actions or other objects
so we're always using these noun verbs
in indigenous languages and that is
something
that talks about um enactment
doing living um
just i don't know i think that that that
one
one way of getting at this is by verbing
the nouns um you know
like like we need to be we need to be
doing
those things um
and and enlivening those concepts
um and that to me
is a way of practicing
um care relationality
that is also about movement and
orientation because it's always in
relationship
to movement and in space and time
yeah i was just going to say this is the
bringing in the being and bringing in
the body
yeah relationship is a doing not a you
know
not a a kind of achievement but as a
doing this
and you know it's just funny because in
black black english if you will
or ebonics it was called briefly or just
black talk
if you will i mean we're constantly
making nouns into verbs
or neal hurston writes about you better
funeralize that
you know if you want to take something
and kind of like put it over there where
it belongs
which is not here uh so yeah this idea
of of concepts helping us
imagine our making and understand our
kind of being
i've been really compelled by this
concept of weathering
and i'm sure you're both a little i'm
sure you're familiar with it but maybe
we could
talk a little bit about the weather
because the weather is bad
and getting worse i was talking to
someone in new orleans early or today
and you know they missed this
current hurricane it went further to the
um
i think to the west than actually
hitting the city this time
and that was today we know california
and you know those are just two examples
um of you know sort of literal weather
if you will
but the weather has become a kind of
trending um theoretical
scaffold to think about black life by
poc life
and of course queer life too what is the
weather and how do you navigate the
weather
i mean we know ancestors did we know
there was ice
age but what is the weather for you and
how are you weathering
the weather it's like the it's like a
meditation when you
imagine the sky and you just watch the
weather change
and you just the practice is to
you know watch the sky and just watch it
all pass without
having a particular emotional attachment
or or noticing your emotional attachment
to the patterns
um and understanding that that's that's
just what it is
i mean i feel like the weather
recently is sullen
it's cloudy it's moody
it's lonely
it's um without its desiring it's hungry
it's thirsty
the weather is just kind of like
it's not in the cute romantic way
it's this longing i think there's just
so much longing
right now and i'm i'm really feeling it
i'm i'm
hearing it i'm sensing it people are
longing for me i'm longing for others
i'm longing for connection you know
across borders i'm i'm longing for um
pleasure and um
and and something immediate too like
some immediate sense of
connection as well um politically
um historically and maybe
right now the weather weathering is
i've also been self-isolating for the
past week
um and
and i think after you know after all of
the
you know learning how to live with all
of the precautions for the past seven
eight months then you know going into a
week or two of isolation
really kind of you're like oh my god
this is like the really hard part of the
meditation practice where you're like
yeah i know all the concepts and i know
what i'm supposed to do and then i have
to practice it by myself for a week or
two
we'll see ah it's um
it's an endurance it's an endurance
practice and
learning how to maybe self-care
regulate self-regulate um
[Music]
and somehow stay open and soft i think
that's my weathering and i can't say
that i'm doing it very well but i think
that's what i'm trying
um there's a beautiful
book uh that is uh it's called the
weather and proust
that is a collection of essays by eve
sedgwick
um and
you know it it talks about
[Music]
buddhism it talks about affect
and it talks about
how
repair emerges
um sometimes through
rupture um
and i think that atmospherics um
is always about
the link between rupturing and repairing
um and
i think that this is something that
i mentioned emily johnson before but i
think that some of
um her work is really beautiful in that
regard
um and and i think that we
um we need to well that we need i say we
need but like
i don't know what we need
um i try to think about
repair and rupture in the same breath
and i try to think about breath
as being both the space of repair and
rupture
i try to think about um emergence
as um that type of space as well
um there's a horizon
in there as well um you know where the
things connect
um the at the begi i've been teaching a
class
about colonial literature which has been
a very interesting
and trying exercise
um so we've been reading columbus
and vespucci and you know
all these all these great guys um
but the first thing we read was the
popol vu
which is the maya story of creation
and the popol starts
with the horizon and
the moment of stillness which is also
the moment of creation
um and so i think that
that is is quintessentially a space
of of rupture creation
and interestingly and this brings it
back to
one of the previous strands of thought
when the world was created
in the vu um
the gods have to first
think meditate before they act
on that creation so this is actually
something
that my students continually come back
to
is that we need to think before we act
um this same protocol is
repeated in the creation of
humans humans that are unable
to think before they act are failed
humans
and they have to be re-done so this is
why
humans are created three times in their
popular because the first two times they
weren't able to think before they acted
right like honestly that explains it all
that's it right there like oh actually
we have to do this another time oh let's
do it another time oh no we didn't
that's why that's why
but like meditation then becomes a
crucial act of creation
meditation is the precursor to creation
[Music]
that's what i take from that
i was just thinking last night i was
lying in bed and talking to my lover on
the phone and i was thinking last night
like
what are all the beautiful things that
were going to that are that are going to
appear
and manifest after this year or two
of really taking deep pause and
reconsidering everything and reorienting
our our way of being in our daily lives
and all these things our relationships
and
assuming that assuming that we are
reorienting right like assuming that we
are actually taking pause and
reconsidering and rethinking and i had
this kind of
little you know glimpse or taste
just beautiful things that i i don't
think i would have known
would come and i just kind of it was
like the first time this year that i was
like oh
that's going to happen and i don't know
what it's going to be and i'm sort of
curious about it
what's it going to look like it's going
to be really deep it's going to be
really
majestic because because my practices
have been so
humbling i think
i'm thinking a little bit about the very
sort of literal
way to render
um jose munoz and queer
career possibility or ideality or
horizon as being always out of reach
um and that you know in that rendering
we move towards queer because it's
somewhere else because this is shitty
this this
blows you know the here and now is
shitty
so then there is is what we're we're
we're trying to turn towards and move
towards
um but there's you know there's a kind
of
terrific critique will so we're never
going to actually experience
black girl magic or joy or black joy or
or queer kind of possibility because
it's always going to be
somewhere else in some other time but
are we being greedy to
think that i should get to have it too
bad if other people do or don't
um what do you make of this idea that uh
a horizon or an action might always be
somewhere else and some other time
on a personal level i'm learning that
that comes from a state of greed
that that comes from the elsewhere is um
a kind of leaning it's you know it's
like a leaning forward or a
or a still being tied up in the past in
this
in a sense of desiring that things were
different desiring that
that we had different things that we
were different
and actually not um perhaps in a way
not being in connection to
just the way the the things you were
talking about this this sort of
connection on so many levels to one
another to
you know human to non-human and vice
versa um
because there is so much abundance
always
and that thirst for
you know something bigger something
better something somewhere else
i think is maybe not taking in the full
reality of what is right here what is
around you and i
i think that also ties a little bit to
kind of the historical erasure
too right like when i think about that i
think about gentrification for example
this
you know these rich histories that are
in a place
um being you know
raised the the the space being raised to
build the better thing the brighter
building and those buildings you know
when we look around
those buildings are badly built and
they're empty
and they don't serve anyone and they're
they're
sterile and so that that constant hunger
for the elsewhere and i have to check
myself too because i have a real like
fantasy life where i'm like oh if i had
over the past 10 years if i hadn't been
so invested in
staying in you know in new york which is
what i call home and
if i had you know quit my job 10 years
ago and
traveled around the world like all these
other artists and my practice would be
this and would be that and so on and so
forth and that's all
i mean that's fantasy it's also a way of
denying myself the pleasure of
what i do have the incredible richness
of the
of the connections and the history and
the work that i've done the communities
that i have here so maybe that's also a
bit of a self-effacing
socialized stance especially for
for folks who are who were socialized
you know um
[Music]
not to be able to fully
digest and um
um enjoy what we do have right there's
something a little bit
self-effacing about that yeah
i think about the um
the directions in
in cherokee in the cherokee tradition
and in other
um traditions where
we have um seven
directions there are the four
cardinal directions there's above
and below and then there's the center
which is where you are now and it's both
a time and a place so
when i get ahead of myself too much
or when i get melancholic and i'm
wildly prone to melancholy
[Laughter]
i can always remember that
all i need to do is
be where i am now
and that is a spiritual place to be
and that is a crucial element to
the the material
reality of my life but also
the spiritual elements
of my life and it helps me be
humble and it helps me
be grounded that being said
um i think that we
lean and we and we
gesture and we yearn
and that is an essential part of
the queer futurity that we're
creating and enacting
and i don't know that that necessarily
means
um being
um egocentric
or ego driven
um because in my
in my reading of munoz that is always a
collective desire
and that is something that
brings world making and worlding
into the picture um
in a way that
like we're all just where we are now but
we're doing it together
and we're going there together and we're
yearning for it
together and and that
seems to me like the type of
utopia that i can get behind
you know like i'm down for that
yeah i love that and
yeah there's something more delicious
when we're doing it together right even
even watching the rainy skies together
it's just
it i've been thinking so much about
companionship
and how important companionship is
and maybe that's the same thing that
we've been talking about already
um that collective desire and that also
that
fantasy and aspiration is also yeah it
creates a space where we actually
where we actually are so whether it's
um you know
[Music]
expressing and claiming
you know our bodies ourselves are
our quote unquote identities and and
what not as
queer and trans folks um
suddenly making space that shatter all
different other kinds of expectations on
our bodies and um
yeah i'm hearing something about just
the space making that happens when it is
a collective act so the difference
between
me yearning by myself and a kind of
desirous yearning with others then
all of a sudden creates like a little
room where we can exist
um that's what i'm hearing
that's the commons right like that's
what commons
yeah like the brown commons
yes yearning in that way
is there something that's about a kind
of like scale
between commons and kin i mean
because i'm trying to i'm i'm kind of
tilting towards how do we rise up
as we need to in our practices
of of you know so we're surrounded by
white supremacy in a certain kind of
capitalist
you know transactional exchange and
things are
lots being put on our bodies constantly
ways to be
productivity models when things need to
happen
like that's just and even though we're
in rona and things
shifted um i'm sure we've all
experienced how they they just keep
coming back
you know things are just like bouncing
back at us like
okay it's different but you still have
to do all this [ __ ] you just have to do
so then you know in our kinship and our
commons there's a way that
i was thinking of commons as maybe being
a question of scale
where the commons doesn't have to
include our kin necessarily
but maybe you have other ways to think
about it that could help us
um kind of address questions of
rebellion
how do you make something that will um
help us reimagine um in the kind of uh
it's not that we want to capitulate to
the time that capitalism
desires of us but what do we do
in response to that that kind of
incessant
need for a certain kind of product and
productivity
what are some of your methods in that
that's the thirst that is that is the
settler colonial thirst
they that is they're
drunk and they need to stop
that's yes
[Laughter]
settlers thirsty i
i could go on about that too but you
know like
i i think that there's a caveat to um
the commons i'm not i'm not like full
full-on
down for the commons in in the sense
that
like commons that are not
rooted in place but rather
are situated on top of indigenous land
is not decolonial
it's just neo-colonial or like
like colonial light and i'm not down for
that
but collective
reciprocal land-backing
care is something that i think
um frees all of us from the
normative limitations of white
supremacist
heteropatriarchy so you know
um yeah period i think
yeah that's it and to to
to reaffirm all the things that we're
saying
[Music]
when all those things are true then
multiplicity
then so many of us are invite so many
more of us get to be at the table
then we get to then we get to repair
together
you know there's this kind of whatever
there's the word
inter what is it inter
[Music]
um
the word that like nonprofit folks use
to talk about a sort of multiplicitous
you know multi-racial multi-ethnic
um collaboration collectivity community
all of that
um it's such a like it's escaping me
but it's it's such a like institutional
word
for what it's worth um
yeah it's like you know this idea of
of oh yeah okay we you know we can like
build these little bridges between us
that's not how it's going to work it's
not going to work that way it's not
going to
that little bridge is just you know it's
um
it's a gesture it's not a meaningful
relationship we're not really at the
table together
often times where maybe tokenized and
representing
you know a small fraction of of
maybe even a stereotypical understanding
of what a whole community or diaspora
might need in this moment and then we're
you know at this strange um like un type
of
um sit down table and and that that ends
up you know
not working and and here we are kind of
staying relatively in the same place
on some levels sometimes because we're
not really
interrelated um and we're not actually
weaving together we're we're just kind
of representing some small facet of
something that someone said that
everybody thinks is important because
you know
a public speaker with a big profile on
twitter has decided that
this is an important thing and like you
look you sometimes you look at
sometimes i look at like sort of like
current political
left a progressive um
thought leadership in a lot of digital
spaces
and i'm like these are concepts from
[Music]
from forever and then also from audrey
lord and also
from thinkers from you know not that
long ago but
but it's getting rebranded by like
these thought leaders that have this
kind of presence and then
i'm wondering also about
what does that mean about like our
connection to our
political thought ancestors and like
what does it mean about
like you know do we do do several
generations kind of lose a
political education then we have to
reformulate it with
folks that are you know our age like
every single
generation um i think that i think the
breakdown
i i sense that there's this breakdown
happening because because of a lack of
memory and also a lack of being able to
access
previous generations in particular also
which might be
kind of a queer phenomenon too
this i mean this is why
multiculturalism and inclusion
and diversity is not
um liberation
you know like the next time yes exactly
on the diversity committee like
come on now yeah that's not it
it's funny just because that you know
diversity came and went
um you know i've been around a little
bit round the block a couple of times at
this point
and diversity did come through as like a
trend and then it went away
and then it came back and you know i'm
super cynical in general
anyway but i was just like really sad
that
this is this seemed to be a kind of like
possibility
for folks who wanted to work in academic
institutions
but maybe less that people who wanted to
caretake
in terms of a kind of physio
intellectual possibility and i do think
that in the best you know
there's some teaching that happens um or
or working in in universities or
or you know middle school or other kinds
of educational address
that is about a possibility of
caretaking
um that it's not always just about
trying to be in front of the room or
become a thought leader although there's
a lot of that
and i'm super super not not into it
um but then diversity like being a
diversity officer
has become now and maybe for a few more
years
something that poc that we can do
and you know i'm really sad about that
but also
want folks to be able to figure out how
to sustain
so it's not like i mean it's a thing you
can do
and it's a place you can work for maybe
eight or ten years
um it seems like that'll be possible
so um i'm not sure what to do with that
beyond the cynicism
about it i think i'm really feeling for
all of my friends and so who
who do so many kinds of work who are
being asked to play that role right now
and
change the museum single-handedly you
know or
change the change the academy
single-handedly or change
the nonprofit industrial complex
single-handedly and i think the thing
that we're all
butting up against it's not a huge
revelation but
those models are still built on
individual responsibility
for one or a small group of people to
caretake for an entire community
with no resources with no
yeah no no place no space and no
resources and so then
we get put in dire positions and it's so
cruel honestly it is so cruel
to do that to bipoc folks
considering considering
our history considering our
understanding considering our lived
experiences considering
what we know and feel you know and we
and we do feel because we are also
in an embodied way processing
um so that white supremacy doesn't have
to
metabolize and fall down so we we
process in our bodies
um so that white supremacy can be
um so that so that it can kind of
go on in this as this sort of like form
that doesn't have to yeah it's
yeah i i'm really feeling for all of my
friends
who are doing all of this work and and
have been and will have to and then
um it is still the individualized
individuated model
of fixing a huge problem with with and
really not
with no generosity from these spaces or
institutions or what have you it's just
kind of a lack of understanding of what
caretaking really
means because i do think that if we if
we
if we made larger agreements as a
society about what caretaking
does entail
somehow i feel like actually it's the
switch is not that hard but it is an
agreement we have to make an agreement
and those agreements have to be pretty
widespread and so that's what i like am
wondering
is it is it possible where does it
happen i know it is happening in in many
places
um i want to know where those spaces are
i want to know
how y'all are doing it and i want us to
talk uh
regularly
this is this is kind of like
operating out of abundance rather than
scarcity
models in which um
poc um
um diversity work
is constantly positioned within a
scarcity model
rather than one of abundance and
i'm for example i'm the diversity
officer for our union
um the faculty and staff union at stony
brook
and so you know like
it's exhausting
and then you know you get brought in
to talk about i'm also the only
indigenous faculty member at
in the entire university which
is one of the larger state
universities in new york we have 20 000
students
and the percentage of black faculty
has actually decreased
over the past 10 years there are fewer
black faculty now than there were 10
years ago
at stony brook
and at the same time we're being asked
to
respond to black lives matter
and so all of a sudden it's oh now we're
gonna have
a panel discussion about this and a
panel discussion about that
with zero understanding of how
the system needs
changing and that change requires
resources and it requires paying faculty
and students and staff
for that time and that labor
because we're constantly being asked to
give the workshop
about this or the give the class about
that
but nobody is getting remunerated for
that time and that
and that energy
and and
for the zoom bombing that happened when
we
did that you know
and people get called racial slurs yeah
you know and like
um so i'm disgruntled about diversity
work right now
uh but i'd still do it because otherwise
the institutions continue on without you
so i think that the word that i have in
my mind about this
is infiltration um
rather than uh
blind participation or
um rather than acceptance or
acquiescence
i would rather infiltrate and ruthlessly
undermine
than i would acquiesce to white
supremacy
that's what i'm that's what i'm
interested in
question
something about i'm trying to line up um
again i did this yesterday too i can't
believe it but i'm not trying to just
hit on orientation as if there's nothing
else
i am wondering if if there's a question
of facing
because there is a way that diversity
work you know re-centers white supremacy
or whiteness
or you know white ignorance white
fragility you know help me feel better
about all the work you're doing help
me understand explain it to me um
so i guess a question that we can move
towards our
are kind of allowing this assemble to
assembly to turn into whatever or else
it wants to be
has to do with where do you how do you
face
and i think you know you've each or
we've all together been saying it over
and over again
um but it's always worth revisiting i
think
if we're not going to face white
supremacy because
you know who wants to do that we're
always involved in it anyway
here's you know foucault's model of
power it's always already there
it's unidirectional can't get out of it
we can't get out of the history that is
built through these these craftings of
white supremacy
but as you've offered us again and again
in our time tonight
we can lean and tilt and gesture
and move and think carefully towards our
abundance
and our ancestors and our possibilities
what does that mean in terms of a facing
where do you want to face
and what happens to the things that you
aren't facing
i sometimes think about like what are
you giving it what are you not giving it
right like we
we acknowledge violence
right we acknowledge harm we acknowledge
um you know coming from like a
transformational justice
kind of lens we have to have the
conversation
right between the parties if you're a
mediator or whatnot
we don't deny an act of violence or a
system
that perpetuates violence but we also
don't give it our
everything necessarily right we don't
let
it we try to figure out how to
acknowledge
the reality without letting it take our
dignity our spirit our sustenance
ourselves and we look for the sort of
transformative
possibilities which also i think comes
back to some kind of
conversation which maybe in and of
itself is a bit limited but
kind of like humanizing right like
humanizing that
uh violence happens through us
it happens to us it happens between us
and ourselves
um and maybe i'm also thinking a bit
back to this question of like you know
the way trauma manifests and actionizes
um how we harm each other how how
i don't know harm is not harm is not
something that is going to be out of the
equation so then it becomes a sort of
transformative justice for me a
conversation about understanding harm
the roots the deep deep deep roots of it
and understanding that we have all been
harmed and so then
can we transform
[Music]
our awareness to understand harm as sort
of
in the mix and also not
um something that we can
it's something that we can actually work
with rather than work around
and maybe you know seeing or or knowing
that so much
harm happens from not acknowledging harm
um sometimes like a harm
you know a harm reduction or like a
transformative red
transformative justice position is like
we have to look at the harm and actually
looking at the harm means looking at the
history of harm
and doing a lot of caretaking work
around that because
everybody is suffering from the
histories of harm
everybody is an acting arm and we all
have to kind of take responsibility and
care
and that's really hard emotionally
that's really hard and as a
as a society especially in a country
that
incarcerates more people within its
borders than any other country in the
world
um looking at that harm looking at that
is looking at the pain and the the
multiple generations
of of suffering that that has caused
that that causes
it's uh you have to be pretty brave i
think
to want to face to to be willing to face
that and to come in with a sense of care
and responsibility
um so yeah folks folks who are doing
that work like
deserve all all of our acknowledgement
and props because they're looking at
things that nobody wants to look at and
you know no no americans really really
want to look at
these histories of harm and i say that
you know
the quote unquote american but
i'm really talking about this sort of
nationhood of like americans don't want
to face
the harm that this country has caused to
its own
folks within its borders and then
everywhere around the world
um
when i was recently teaching
about uh columbus
and the diaries uh
that columbus wrote
the first mention of
people in the indies
or the americas was that
they saw naked people
that's the line and
there's also an orientation
in that who's doing the looking and
who's being looked at
and this is an initial gesture
of objectification and
of capture
in which the colonial gaze
um
hones in on a naked
indigenous body and that is the model
of vision and of
power that has been
perpetuated ever since then
so how we look how we
orient ourselves in many ways has been
conditioned from that initial
interpolation so i'm constantly
trying to find ways of
alternative
gesturings and leanings
and sometimes it's so the weight of it
all
is so much that it's
it's hard to turn it's hard to
reorient but
um if we can
think of the other side of that
gaze on the shore
then we can shift the perspective
and we can start to imagine otherwise
um and so for me
this is where um
thinking with our stories
thinking with our understandings
of kinship reorients
us from
our own epistemological framework and
cosmological framework
rather than the one that has been
imposed for
500 years um
and because the stories that we have are
much older than 500 years
and they have the wisdom of generations
and generations of ancestors
um
i think i'll leave it there
generations and generations time um
repair is something i want to really
dream about tonight
because it wasn't something i had
thought of in relationship to
i don't know um this time and
and i'm really appreciative of that
concept
among so many others um care we kind of
really
sat with for our awful lot of our
conversation caregiving
someone in the chat was asking a
question about bottoming if you will
um you know what is it to to be
concerned with
um the posterior or the background um
and i know we could spill spin that open
in many directions
for for hours and hours and hours if not
lifetimes
um and maybe that's our challenge and
task is to do that
in practice
and to keep keep sort of um aware of the
work that there is the last thing i
heard you both say to me in a certain
kind of way was
this this labor is ongoing and it's
difficult
um and you've also helped remind me that
you know we have strategies and we do
have
we have tactics and we have ways uh
to keep engaging this work if we can
keep
figuring out how to connect through care
and a careful kind of rendering of our
shared possibilities
um jared's going to come in to have a
thing or two to say
um before we'll do our our closing
ritual if you will
um thank you that was amazing again
um really i don't have much to say other
than i just wanted to thank everybody
um especially the panelists and
especially our asl
team who are so phenomenal um
and also to remind people that it's
happening again tomorrow but it's going
to be at a slightly different time to
try to accommodate
joy mariama smith's who is coming to us
from amsterdam
um i believe um and it's joy and
jumatatupo
yes so can it just be another beautiful
beautiful time so join us for that if
you can and these will all be recorded
and hosted both on the lion's jaw
website and probably eventually at mit
as well
so that's it for me so we thank trisha
and hercules they're amazing
we thank you know each other for finding
our way together
and um you know if you want to
unmute and give a shout out in in sound
if you
like to the the folks the panelists and
just thank you so much
um joseph thank you marbles i see you
marbles yes thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you everybody
much appreciation bye
so beautiful thank you
watch the stars blink out yes
see you lovely folks tomorrow yes thank
you so much
you